when there's no music you will be the
first to know Taylor Swift didn't drop
new music but did debut a piece you do
well beats yes wins best fan army what
we do without the iHeartRadio awards
went down in Los Angeles Thursday night
any tease
taking a look at the most memorable
moments of the iHeartRadio Music Award
[Music]
Kacey Musgraves and Chris Martin teamed
up for a beautiful rendition of her song
rainbow this album is very personal to
me and I just feel like the people who
have connected with it has just shown it
so much love and so much positivity it's
just gone and done things that I just
really I just could have never dreamed
of
I also just need to say before I go that
I love your passion I love your
attention to detail I love how much you
care I'm not seeing all the things that
you're posting online and I just wanted
to let you know that when there's new
music you will be the first to know well
Taylor Swift carefully let her fans down
revealing she would not be dropping new
music during the awards show as she
accepted her trophy for tour of the year
[Applause]
Alicia Keys won the innovator award and
an eye witness tells et Taylor Swift and
Maren Morris were the first to give the
singer a standing ovation and the crowd
followed suit quote not a single person
was sitting down as Alicia took the
stage and was joined on the piano by her
eight-year-old son Egypt while husband
Swizz Beatz and their other son genesis
danced along
my father
[Music]
[Applause]
Backstreet Boys performed that epic
throwback and bts's loyal followers won
them best fan army ahead of embarking on
her world tour ariana grande won the
iHeartRadio artist of the Year award and
performed her new song needy for the
first time
[Music]
the iHeartRadio artist of the decade and
my hero later Chris Pratt took the stage
alongside his favorite singer Garth
Brooks the one artist of the decade
[Applause]
[Music]